for weeks now Paris's main landmarks
have been quiet silenced by a virus
that's wreaked havoc across France since
March the 17th people ordered to stay
home lockdown rules further tightened at
the beginning of April when all outdoor
activities in Paris were banned but
still the number of deaths from
coronavirus continued to rise health
care workers on the front line among the
dead su soir
tonight our country has reached a
symbolic and particularly painful
milestone with more than 20,000 deaths
as the growing need for food banks has
shown the lockdown has also highlighted
Frances inequalities in mid April civil
unrest broke out in Paris's northern
suburbs over claims that police were
using heavy-handed tactics against
minorities the economy has also been hit
hard by the lockdown France is
officially in recession with its biggest
contraction since the end of the second
world war with pressure mounting it's no
wonder politicians have been so
desperate to begin opening up the
country once again never in the history
of our country have we seen this
situation not even during the war not
during the occupation not during
previous epidemics never never has the
country been confined as it is today
Erbs france's President Emmanuel macron
is the latest world leader hoping to
save his country without costing more
lives
for more let's bring in DWS Lisa Lewis
standing by for us in Paris good morning
to you Lisa a breath of fresh air this
morning in Paris but not all the country
is opening the same way some areas are
being classified as red zones what's
happening in those areas yes absolutely
the overseas territory Marriott for
example there
the restrictions are not being lifted
yet in other areas in eastern France and
here in the Paris region that means that
public parks and schools will not open
for now and here in Paris during Russia
or public transport it is a more
restricted cells you will still need a
document saying that you need to take
public transport three hours in the
morning three hours in the afternoon
early evening to show that you need to
take it and actually for example to go
to work because the public transport
companies here want to limit the amount
of the passenger amount to 15 percent of
its normal volume really what's the
people what's the government going to do
rather to get people back to work
projections right now are are indicating
that this lack of activity public
activity will lead to a contraction of
at least 8 percent of the French economy
what's the government going to do to get
the people back into their jobs well the
government is spending 110 billion euros
to get the economy back on track it will
provide subsidies for companies its
financing unemployment benefits for up
to 8 million additional people at the
moment it's trying to alleviate
employers charges so that companies can
stay afloat and it is saying obviously
at the moment you know people should go
back to work but those who can work from
home should stay at home so that the the
transporter and other parts of the
cities don't get overcrowded and the
spread of the impending epidemic will
not increase again okay what's the mood
against this kind of background a lot of
uncertainty out there this morning
as a Paris as the country reopens how
are people feeling about all of us well
two-thirds of the French are worried
about the lifting of restrictions
restrictions and you can see that
actually some people were fearing that
public transports and trains etc and the
roads would be overcrowded but that's
not the case many people are saying you
know we're going to stay at home watch
the situation they're really wary of of
this virus and of the fact that it could
spread even faster than beforehand so
many people fear a second wave of this
and are staying at home also schools are
now bit by bit
rope in reopening again across the
country and two-thirds of the parents
are actually saying you know we're going
to keep our children at home that's an
option for at least a few weeks now okay
Lisa thanks so much for that from Paris
this morning